Cheetah are in a race for survival.
There are maybe just 7,000 adult cheetah left in the wild.
I've covered the illegal
trafficking networks
draining the Horn of Africa
of their cheetah.
They also face massive
habitat loss, and retaliatory
killings by herders when
cats prey on their livestock.
I want to find out
what's being done
to try and rescue
cheetah from the brink.
How do captive breeding
programs like this
help to grow wild
populations of cheetah?
It essentially boils
down to genetics.
There is a lack of diversity
in the current wild
populations that we have,
and we need to put healthy
genetics back into it.
Part of the phased 're-wilding'
is that we're starting to
disassociate normal captive
settings around them.
When I open up that crate and a
cat gets released into a reserve,
it gives me goosebumps
every single time.
One of our initial cats, that we re-wilded, her name was Khatu.
She's one of our
success stories, and
she's currently on her third
litter already in the wild.
I think she's around, but I will
use my telemetry to track her.
Yeah.
So you have a collar on her?
She has a collar, yes.
She's here, with a kill.
Oh wow I see her!
So the cubs they run away.
It's really rare for the
cheetah to get six cubs,
but this one, she does this
for the second time now.
Cheetah like Khatu and her cubs
could be the key to
ensuring that the fastest
land animal on earth isn't
consigned to history.
But it must happen
alongside efforts
to stop trafficking,
habitat loss and poaching.
Around the world, big cats
like lions and tigers
continue to be traded
and kept captive in
inhumane conditions,
but they can be rescued
and moved to properly
managed wildlife sanctuaries.
That can mean a journey of thousands of miles.
I've just been a great animal
lover my whole life.
When you're talking
about Eastern Europe,
there are no facilities, there
are no sanctuaries there
for big cats.
So we've got to bring them out.
I met someone and I moved over
to Ukraine to be with them.
And that is when I got involved
in the rescue and relocation
of abused wildlife.
We knew we needed to
get these cats out.
I got on the phone,
and I called DHL,
and within days they
had made a decision
that they could do this.
So in total, the cats spent 87
hours in those travel crates.
The one cat Khaya,
shes been been locked in a
garage size for three years.
Concrete and steel.
She's never been
anywhere else.
And to open that door,
she doesn't know that she can
step across that threshold.
You'll be surprised how
quickly they adapt
and they'll just be taken
care of and loved
in the way that we can love them,
and let them just be lions.